chat gpt lehetőséget ad arra hogy
dokumentumokat csatoljunk például egy
pdf dokumentumot hogyha csatolunk akkor
bele tudunk kérdezni ebbe a pdf
dokumentumba ami hihetetlenül hasznos
mert később majd jövök egy olyan tippel
hogy hogyan tudunk nagyon hatékonyan
tanulni a chat gpt segítségével így
ugyanígy képeket lehet csatolni amiket
felismer és tudunk kérdezni a képekkel
kapcsolatban ez különösen hasznos
például amikor lefényképezünk egy idegen
nyelvű szöveget és megkér a chat gpt-t
hogy fordítsa le számunkra például
angolra ez konkrétan akkor történt meg
velem amikor egy kínai étterembe
kerültem és a menü csak kínai
karakterekkel
volt olvasható lefényképeztem az oldalt
és gyakorlatilag a chat gpt egy pillanat
alatt lefordította számomra magyarra
rákérdezhettem hogy mi van milyen
összetevők vannak benne megkérdezhettem
hogy milyen ételeket ajánl hogyha a
családommal vagyunk itt és kisgyerek
vannak tehát például pikáns étel ne
legyen benne úgyhogy hihetetlenül ha
tudjuk hogy aat gpt képes erre is